hey guys B peppers here and as you can
see with the leaves blowing by that's a
windy level so I wanted to do a
walk-through with commentary to talk
about and this is level 18 one of the
hard ones in the beginning of farm here
super saga we're just gonna talk about
how to get this ACORN at the top down
here to the squirrel at the bottom so
there's a couple different kinds of
squirrel levels but this one is a windy
one so whichever way we we match the the
crop sees is the way it'll move so if I
move this purple one over here then you
know he's gonna move to the right so if
we want to move an object either the
squirrel or the thing right we you know
we match to the right if we want to move
it down we match below it when I move it
up and so on and so forth so the
toughest part about these I think is
getting them together so I go ahead and
do that first the the collections aren't
that bad and another thing to remember
is if you make make a super crop see
right next to the squirrel he'll he'll
do like the hill stretch his tail out a
little bit further and he'll get it even
when they're right not together so you
can look to do that too you can also
switch whenever the whenever he's out
running around you can switch him with
the crop seat or you can do the same
with the acorn so that's another thing
to keep in mind too so here I can make
the super crop see next to him and watch
he'll don't hit it even though it's a
little bit further away so when you're
planning things out you're gonna want to
go like that you want to kind of you
know just just playing your matches so
that you don't move them further away
from each other unless you get stuck in
a point where you have to
and we just have to collect the rest of
the the crops here remember that when
you make super crop sees that you get
that number it'll stay on it so when you
match it you can collect it again it
doesn't it doesn't disappear after the
other matches you can see so that red
one at the bottom it's worth 20 right
now so I get set up this match right
here and then that Oh that'll finish the
collection for me because it'll take all
those numbers at once and show time we
just you know gonna try to match
whatever ones we had quite a few moves
left so they made a bunch of big ones
for us here so we'll just match them
together the best ones at the bottom
first even though they don't drop since
it's a windy level that's kind of what I
was thinking but I'll just make the rest
of them up so hopefully hopefully this
helps to understand some of the basics
okay so this is one of the earlier
tougher windy squirrel levels so it can
be a little frustrating to move them
around that water but just plant things
out and you'll get it eventually got any
questions leave a comment please like
the video if you found it helpful and
make sure you subscribe to my channel I
think I'm going to put some time into
farm here super it's a pretty fun game
and so I'll be making more videos like
this soon talk to you later